warum fängt er mit seiner musik man zu
spielen ich bin leider im haus auf einer
fängt musiker zu spielen
die musik wird lauter
servus heute und herzlich willkommen zur
ersten folge von teil 1 22 was ist dir
gedacht cod teilten zwei oder wie das
ist die vp projekt es ist sehr nice und
es geht in drei sekunden die mitte
minecraft ist kein schwert las ich auch
nicht auch nicht wissen wo wir herkommen
klar ist wenn du jetzt jemand lockt mit
schwertern bregtal welche ab dass hier
das hier ein junge sein auftritt nicht
so dumm laufen ins haus damals erst mal
stärker machen wir schon mal schwerter
hält was machst du heute ja da muss uns
nicht sagt vielleicht anders wahr was
force.com treffe ich habe den mythos ist
ob sie fanden als buchmacher schönbuch
bensdorf bisschen aufgeregt schwert
sondern hautnah wieder zerstörte der
träume malta das war das rad machen
von marie-sophie wusste bewusstlosen
namen maßnahmen ich sehe nichts aber bei
mir liefs zu übertrieben für sehen wer
mir auch nicht bei mir auch nicht passen
zusammen suchen kommt dann so marita
reeker rechts ja alles easy komme da
werden mitteldrittel getränk dass das
haupt noch haupt naturhorn bunse und man
kann ihn nicht pusten müssen als lag ein
bisschen ok hautnah ist schonmal
separiert liegt auf jeden fall ja ich
habe mir keine hitze und ich gehe ja
nicht meine art treffen
herr ott pvp kleine hinterherlaufen tobi
lauf lauf labbrig kann haut nämlich
hätten was ist das ich kann die nicht
hätten ihn jung was ist das denn
what the [ __ ] was los ich kann den typen
nicht hinten was ist es findet kommt
bekommst du und ich bin down
das ist doch ein scheiß witz alter
wieso kann ich den typen nicht hätten
okay ich bin ich bin froh und ich würde
es mal kurz erklären und zwar das
problem ist folgendes ich habe gedacht
das hautnah jemanden getötet hatte aber
tatsächlich wurde hauptmann getötet und
das bedeutet dass haupt nach zwei
minuten spawn protection hatte nach
seinem respawn und deswegen konnten wir
nicht hätten daran haben wir erstens
nicht angedacht weil die aufregung doch
zu groß war im zweiten hatten wir
gedacht hautnah hätte jemanden getötet
und nicht dass er getötet wurde
das missverständnis wie möglich auf der
server würde lecken oder so ja nun das
zu erklären weiter mit dem video usb
laufwerk noch weglaufen junge was ist
das findet das gibt's doch nicht komisch
what fragt alter ok komme auf folgt mir
folgt mir alles gut gelaufen erst mal
ein bisschen wegnehmen aber schon mal
weizen mit ihrer weithin meisten und so
daten von kindern zwei familien since
worden
deutschland ist aktiv fall stand ist
aktiv aufpassen was für ein scheiß man
verstehe ich auch du konntest ihn auch
nicht hätten
hatte die wieder die nofx an der kleinen
dinge als ich konnte ihn nicht retten
ich war so nah dran also what the [ __ ]
leute so startet man in einem projekt
ppp projekt erstmal gegner nicht hätten
können dann sterben okay das war aber
hier drüben kann man zum beispiel machen
halte man ausschau
das stattliche abbaukammern bisschen
runter kommt nicht aufhalten
da drüben ist schon das recht aber
immerhin wurde ich diesmal nicht von
tobi geschützt hey meine will ich
diesmal nicht
doch gut von den buddies getötet aber
bord da fragt man ich konnte einfach
nicht hinten kommt kommst du mit
damaligen ausstellen
doch das lag aber nur ein bisschen nach
den ausstellungen den regen ich weiß
nicht was wissen machen
aber aufpassen nicht so weit weg
hab dich jetzt kurz aus dem blick
verloren macht müsste vorne art zu essen
uns einstellen
ein brot
tiere sind auch die nächste return gar
keine dass sie auch profis mit runter
gedrückt oder rasanter ein neuer volle
kanne aber erwarten fleisch wenig esse
ich hab ein schwert aus dem stein stein
und essen oder hasst herr stein für
stein
vielleicht schaffen es in der ersten
folge hongkong dpa es gibt ja aber ich
will angreifen schwert machen ja man
warum hast du keine als komm mit ich
will mir aber ein geschäft machen ein
eisen schwer ist das moor wo ja doch
sieht man im chat es ist aber keiner
oben ist ein gegner bitte sei macht
faxen mit diesem komischen sperrte warum
mach ich mir jetzt schnell auch noch
eins mach bitte keine faxen nach ja
immer schnell damit keine faxen machen
sondern wie schwerter um sind zwar
gegner lassen sie holen hier hast du
hast du jetzt ein stein ist dagegen auch
groß hat ein von der aufgrund einer
runter geworfen oder egal wir sind sehr
effizient und ich kann locker nicht mehr
zu den sprinten ja okay dann bleibe ich
bei dir wie du vorher vor
leute es noch zwei freunde sind die
freunde also ich regeneriere ja ich auch
nicht egal wie viel risiko dass haben
uns gesagt leute nicht dass ihr euch
wundert was hier los ist
spiel nicht hier oben oder wie ich sie
nicht dabei sind links gegangen
diesen links wieder den berg hoch hier
links spitze gegangen er sicher ich
meine ich an die wand dahinter oder
kannst du noch rote karten
leider nicht mehr dahin doch denken sind
die spd tätig sind wären bestimmt auch
nicht
ich habe auch nur noch einen beat hast
du vielleicht noch einzeln kann einer
von zehn spenden ein weizen habe ich
noch ich haben 13 filmbruder damit kommt
man nicht weiter wir bleiben ganz dicht
zusammen weil wir haben könne nicht mehr
spenden also der bei mir nicht dass
jetzt tiere holen in unseren weg kommt
sind wir vorne sind ihre der vordersten
front
ok ich bleib direkt hinter dir bleibt
vor mir sind unsere freundin wird team
nächste denn wir sind emails oder links
und rechts machen
da vorne los geht's bei solchen fahrten
sachen drin schweizer trio ja es gibt
nämlich special bauten mal wird brennan
war oder aber hast dann offen
ich will die kehlmann ich will die
kinder ich werde auch geld sind die rein
gegangen oder niemals waren da hinten
echt niemals ist dahinter aber wie
kriegen wir nicht oder ist schwierig
aber dann nehme ich würde dir auch gerne
angreifen ja
der erfolg von diesem betrieb von diesen
zieht damit kann man sich täuschen
assistance rüstung machen und da hinten
das eisen
noch mehr citrin das finden auch
schwerter machen echt und die die haben
25.000 chance also es gibt richtig geile
erweiterungen bauen wir alles ab was du
trägst also dass für die ost auszuweisen
also leute wichtig erklärt was das ist
schau doch mal kurz auf den ausgang wenn
ich etwas abbauen
allerdings haben wir nicht reiten essen
pvp projekt mit über 40 gegnern richtig
großen wenig hat er schon gesehen die
buddys pokal und angreifbar hacks
buddies ak
diesmal fielen sie mich mit
übernatürlichen kräften nichts gehört
nichts gehört gerade hat auch nicht
gesagt glaube ich mir aber die sache ist
ist ein neues projekt es gibt hier im
wesentlichen drei erweiterungen und zwar
eine rüstung die kraft konnte man sich
ausländer materialien die gibt einem
feuer resistenz das netzwerk kann
verbrennen in der 50 prozentigen chance
das kann man kräfte man sich aus den
materialien heißt wir sollten bald einen
elfer eigentlich dazu gibt es dann die
zieht ried rüstung heißt es glaube ich
dass dieser gelbe stoff wie die zitrone
die rüstung gibt resistenz gegen also
mit der rüstung kann man auch ein feuer
in lava schwimmen sogar so groß ist die
volle distanz wenn die vollständig ist
und die citrix ist und gibt
vollständigkeit resistenz gegengift zum
beispiel und es schwert hat eine 25
prozentige vergiftung chance recht hat
genau zu meinen beitrag dazu
wir brauchen unbedingt noch ein iron
mindestens ist auch im ganzen land weil
ich eigentlich abgebaut was da also ein
bisschen lecks noch damit wir diese
materialien zählen können das vorsieht
ihren ich pack das mal da das wäre schon
sinnvoll wenn wir die nicht mal hast du
kohle zufällig abgebaut oder darum
seinen doch darum hier guckt buskohl da
hier oben wo ich auch was habe ich
zufällig selbst ganz lecks im cineplex
altersjahr in bester war romania sehr
schön die lenz hervor dem baby hat
einfach überhaupt keine lex hat michi
sie dreimal gerettet
ein bisschen ärgerlicher anfangen es
werden aber keine leben wegen lecks
zurückerstattet und des lebens system
ist so jedes thema drei leben solange
das team mehr als nur leben hat darf man
respawn dem es noch 1 man verliert für
jeden tod ein leben für jeden kinder
kriegt man ein halbes zurück ja ja und
wir wollen so ein bisschen draufgänger
machen wie man bei war sind wir immer
wissen sie eigentlich jeder sehr
defensiv und hier bin ist das eine gute
gelegenheit mal was anderes
auszuprobieren
dann bauen wir kurz noch ein bisschen
von diesem ziel ablenke raus ich spiele
möchte mal wissen was das hier drunter
ist das rentenalter grüne wolle man ja
nicht dass deine falle ist es gibt auch
fallen auf der map regierung würde ich
mal sagen ziemlich sicher gibt's ja
verhalten leute job nikolaus der wand
es ist dass man die job noch mal ich
habe sich einige kreise
ich stehe das nicht aber man muss auch
sagen es ist also arbeit ja eine menge
arbeit reingesteckt ist sollte man jetzt
auf gar keinen fall madig reden also das
schon eine gute sache die sie auf die
beine gestellt haben wir haben jetzt
noch vielleicht vergessen die über world
vorzuladen
wir brauchen definitiv noch ein dings
mehr drin weil das wäre echt schade wenn
wir die dias und so weiter
mehr ein weiteres allen fehlt noch
einmal den eingang davon zu bauen was
ich nicht da konnte ich mal drei steckt
also mein leben ist vorbei
ja und dann schaute mich nicht so ja und
ja und ihr spiel machen
es kommt also ist es ein bisschen
strange davon nutzen können aber freunde
wir werden weil sie nächste folge
einfach wenn wir jetzt die sachen
kriegen das aber nicht vor gericht als
frauen weil die aufnahmezeit beträgt 15
minuten folge wir nehmen es schon zwölf
minuten auf das wir müssen endlich
gekickt werden
deshalb sollten wir wirklich
ok kriegst du noch kohle irgendwie ja
auch mal hier unten ist hier ins tor
passieren
walter ja gucken ob du nirgendwo eisen
mit bekommst was hat es damit auf sich
hat will ich bleibe hier oben erstmal
ich schau mal hier und morgen was ist
oder wie man das machen
ich freue mich sehr über dieses grünen
zeugs besucht das ganze ja sehr gut das
ist sehr gut dann kann man nämlich schon
am postweg machen wir müssen also mit
uns nur noch ein einziger moment hätte
dass ich war oder auf je besser also das
ist der wahnsinn das ist der wahnsinn
neue rolle jetzt steht uns nicht so
außer dass wir vielleicht ein
verfluchtes drecks fuhren einen noch
brauchen
darf man so sagen ja dazu sagen mit
softbox ist ich sage ich und ich kann
nicht erkennen
wir kennen vielleicht besser im video
muss man auch fackeln machen weil die
meisten glaube ich zumindest zu einem
zeitpunkt also in der kunden geschrieben
ein gamma verändern
die glasfenster um abbauen über die
grösse in der höhle dann kann man die
abwahl
also ein eisen haben im ofen hier ne wie
viel das habe ich selbst auch noch eins
im station
du hast ja genau dann reicht es schon
mal man hier ist nur queenston ist der
ärzte sachen gar nicht in den ofen rein
vielleicht sogar so ein open also
vielfalt eine neue strategie werden wir
auf jeden fall mehr kunden aber ich
komme einfach gerade nicht den ofen rein
das nämlich nur von einer anderen seite
hörst du mich max ich kann gar nicht
ausnehmen vw team aus ich glaube der
service gecrasht warum fängt am mittag
auf einer musik band zu spielen
ich bin leider im haus auf aber fängt
musiker zu spielen
ich bin gerade form von server
runtergeflogen die musik mit lauter
fakt ist dass ich bin auf dem server
geführt hätte meine meiner bude spuckt
einfach wie heute dann war es soweit von
der ersten folge taten
wir haben sehr enttäuschend leichen
gefunden und ich musste erst mal nach ob
mir etwas gucken was denn los dass man
das kann ich das einfach musik spielt
leute team es ist für euch am start
chaotische erste folge die basis legen
gibt er folgende titel in den
kommentaren marketingzwecken
wir sehen uns der nächste wieder haut
rein macht's gut und hat einen schönen
tag